[Musik]
kein ende der gewalt in nahost auf
raketenangriffe aus gaza reagiert israel
mit panzern aus der eu und aus der luft
unser reporter ist an der grenze zum
gazastreifen
die fdp will wieder mitregieren auf
ihrem parteitag führen die liberalen
parteichef lindner zum spitzenkandidaten
für die bundestagswahl und vollen
drittstärkste kraft werden
ab in die sonne griechenland öffnet
seine strände wieder für touristen die
ersten deutschen sind bereits gelandet
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute -nachrichten am freitag
zusammen mit norbert lehmann der den
sport präsentiert ein showprogramm tor
von mir
es sind die heftigsten kämpfe seit dem
gazakrieg von 2014 mehr als 120 menschen
wurden bislang getötet vor allem auf
palästinensischer seite beide seiten
attackieren sich unentwegt weiter
die islamistische hamas feuert raketen
nach tel aviv die israelische armee
konnte mit einem großangriff auf den
gazastreifen aus der luft und mit
panzern beschuss seit montagabend wurden
von dort mehr als 1800 raketen
abgefeuert und auch aus dem libanon
sollen vereinzelt raketen auf
israelisches gebiet geflogen sein
israels militär erhöht den druck mit
panzern artillerie und weiteren
luftschlägen dabei zivile opfer zu
vermeiden sei nicht möglich heißt es
antoine kurschilgen seit der nacht
verstärkt israel noch einmal seine
militäroperationen im gazastreifen die
luftwaffe bombardiert stellungen der
hamas unterstützt von bodentruppen im
grenzgebiet das ziel der israelischen
militär intervention ist klar der
angriff gestern nacht war gewidmet dem
terror tunnel netzwerk der hamas
untergasse city aus der luft haben wir
gestern nacht angegriffen und dieses
tunnelnetz wird größtenteils zerstört
der morgen nach der israelischen
operation zerstörte häuser im
gazastreifen die angriffe gelten die
hamas aber sie treffen auch zivilisten
die israelis haben uns eine minute
gegeben damit wir uns in sicherheit
bringen können
da haben wir eine tote familie gefunden
die frau war schwanger wir haben keine
schuld wir sind hier nur kinder frauen
und mein kranker vater ich weiß nicht
warum sie uns das antun
die intensität des raketenbeschuss aus
gaza lässt trotz der israelischen
angriffe kaum nach die hamas setzt
inzwischen auch drohnen mit sprengsätzen
ein wie auf diesem propaganda video zu
sehen und israels premier netanjahu
stellt klar diese militär operation wird
so lange dauern wie nötig um ruhe und
sicherheit wiederherzustellen
die zweite front sind israels städte ich
wiederhole was ich gesagt habe wir geben
der polizei und den sicherheitskräften
100 prozent rückhalt um recht und
ordnung wiederherzustellen
aber davon sind israels städte weit
entfernt immer wieder gibt es
auseinandersetzungen zwischen arabischen
und jüdischen israelis trotz massiver
verstärkungen der polizeikräfte und die
konnten aber nicht verhindern dass auch
gestern wieder eine synagoge in brand
gesteckt wurde
kein ende der gewalt in sicht auch an
der anderen front bei schrott drei
kilometer vom gazastreifen entfernt ist
die flugabwehr der israelischen armee
seit tagen im einsatz
unser korrespondent michael b warum ist
an der grenze zum gazastreifen ins der
rott michael was können sie über die
situation in gaza streifen berichten wir
stehen hier ungefähr auf der höhe des
nordzipfel des gazastreifens wo die
großen luftangriffe in der nacht von
israel aus hin geführt haben und dann
den ganzen morgen weiter gegangen sind
um das tunnelnetz zu zerstören aber wir
haben es gesehen auch die
zivilbevölkerung ist in leidenschaft
gezogen israel wird diese kampagne
allerdings sicherlich noch einige tage
weiter führen und wie sieht es auf
israelischer seite bei ihnen aus
ja wir sind heute am frühen abend hier
mal durch die rot gefahren die straßen
sind menschenleer die menschen bleiben
zu hause
wir wurden live zeuge eines
raketenangriffs und dann sieht man wie
wenig zeit bleibt es gibt keine sirenen
keine vorwarnung in 10 sekunden sind die
raketen was die rote und so viel zeit
hat man dann auch einen der vielen
mobilen schutzbunker am straßenrand zu
erreichen
umso dankbarer sind die menschen für
diese batterien hier hinter uns vom iron
dome kurz vor der sendung ist eine
rakete auf wieder abgefeuert worden und
viele menschen kommen her und bringen
ganz spontan etwas zu essen geschenke
und bedanken sich so für die arbeit der
soldaten hier die ihnen tatsächlich den
himmel frei halten und das leben retten
vielen dank michael beverungen aus der j
die neue gewalt im nahen osten wird auch
hierzulande viele menschen auf manche
auf den straßen fordern nur eine
friedliche lösung
andere gehen weiter zu weit befinden
polizei verbände und politik gemeint
sind ausschreitungen vor deutschen
synagogen und antisemitische parolen
judenhass ganz gleich von wem wollen und
werden wir in unserem land nicht dulden
sagte der präsident steinmeier der bild
-zeitung mathis feldhoff
es ist eine erschreckende szenerie
mittwoch am frühen abend unweit der
jüdischen synagoge in gelsenkirchen aus
einem protestzug heraus ertönt plötzlich
antisemitischen sprechchöre
scheiß juden skandieren die
demonstranten noch bevor sie die
synagoge erreichen werden sie von der
polizei gestoppt
die bundeskanzlerin betont heute
demonstrationen gehörten zur demokratie
allerdings nicht solche so der
regierungssprecher
wer solche proteste aber nutzt um seinen
judenhass herauszuschreien der
missbraucht das demonstrationsrecht
antisemitische kundgebungen wird unsere
demokratie nicht dulden
an vielen gebäuden wurden heute
solidarisch israelische flaggen gehisst
sowie vor der hessischen staatskanzlei
aber auch auf solche symbole gab es
anschläge im thüringischen nordhausen
konnte die polizei noch die reste einer
brandbombe fotografieren während am
nachmittag vor der synagoge in
gelsenkirchen eine mahnwache statt
findet fragt der zentralrat der juden
nach der verantwortung der muslime in
deutschland
steinwürfe auf synagogen sie ist keine
politische äußerung sondern reine um
pure antisemitismus es wurde versäumt in
den letzten jahren gerade auch von
muslimischer seite dieses die diese
thematik aktiv anzugehen
es sind oft proteste auf der strasse wie
heute in berlin die eskalationspotenzial
haben die muslime betonen den
zusammenhalt die juden könnten sicher
sein dass wir es nicht zulassen dass
extremisten versuchen diesen konflikt im
nahen osten dafür zu nutzen auf unserem
boden hier in deutschland das weiter
auszutragen es wird mit uns muslimen
nicht zu machen sei wie ernst die
behörden die lage nehmen zeigt sich
heute auch am polizeiaufgebot sei 2013
ist christian lindner chef der fdp heute
hat in seiner partei mit 93 prozent
bestätigt das ist sein bislang bestes
ergebnis
außerdem wurde er zum spitzenkandidaten
für die bundestagswahl gekürt
bis sonntag wollen die liberalen auf
ihrem digitalen parteitag auch das
programm beschließen mit dem sie in den
nächsten vier monaten um wählerstimmen
werben
bernd benthin der mit abstand
dienstälteste parteivorsitzende ist
christian lindner mittlerweile seit acht
jahren im amt jetzt für zwei weitere
wiedergewählt
gab es mehr zu tun so lauten
wahlkampfslogan und lindners
grundbotschaft heute unsere
wirtschaftliche basis haben wir nicht
gestärkt sondern nur verteilt und
zunehmend verbraucht unsere soziale
sicherung ist brüchig geworden wie es
ist kann es nicht bleiben
ihre bereitschaft zum mitregieren betont
die liberalen seit monaten nach
aktuellen umfragen ginge das gerade am
ehesten mit grünen und spd beide
parteien sprechen über höhere steuern
zur pandemie bewältigung die aber
schließt lentner aus ist es denn
wirklich ratsam nach einer
wirtschaftskrise so viele reserven
verbraucht worden sind jetzt zusätzliche
belastungen anzukündigen
wir glauben nicht vor einem jahr kratzte
die fdp in umfragen an der fünf prozent
hürde
aktuell steht sie im zdf politbarometer
bei zehn prozent die eigene erklärung
das betonen der freiheitsrechte in der
korona pandemie zahle sich jetzt aus
wenn die verteidiger der freiheit und
des rechtsstaats mit populisten
verglichen werden dann sollte uns das
nicht irritieren
es sollte uns zu noch mehr anspornen für
die freiheit und den rechtsstaat zu
streiten wenn das populismus ist dann
willig populist sein
bis sonntag noch berät die fdp über ihr
wahlprogramm
einige wenige in einer berliner halle
die meisten vor dem computer zu hause
wie ausgeprägt ist denn der regierungs
wille der fdp diesmal frank buchwald
sehr stark in das zentrale botschaft
hier lautet wir wollen wieder
mitregieren in welcher koalition und
konstellation auch immer es kann man vor
allem auf die inhalte an
neben liberalen klassikern die
steuerentlastung gibt sich die fdp
deshalb auch ein etwas ökologisches und
sozialeres profil keine scharfen
angriffe deshalb gegen die grünen statt
dessen klares bekenntnis zum klimaschutz
wenn auch mit marktwirtschaftlichen
mitteln
enttäuschten wählern von cdu und spd
will lindner ein angebot machen und in
zeiten der pandemie präsentiert sich die
fdp als partei der freiheit und der
bürgerrechte und besinnt sich auf alte
lang vergessene traditionen
vielen dank frank frank buchwald vom
parteitag der fdp zum thema corona die
der blick auf die aktuellen zahlen
stimmt weiter hoffnungsvoll
das robert koch institut meldet rund
11.300 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
über 7.000 weniger als vor einer woche
190 menschen starben in verbindung mit
cupid 19
bundesweit fällt die sieben tage
incident auf 96,5 und damit erstmals
nach fast zwei monaten wieder unter 100
wegen des gestrigen feiertags wurde
allerdings weniger getestet und gemeldet
der rückgang bei den infektionen hängt
auch mit dem fortschritt beim impft
tempo zusammen
allein am mittwoch wurden mehr als 1,35
millionen menschen geimpft ein neuer
tagesrekord gut 36 prozent der deutschen
haben bisher die erste spritze bekommen
der fokus soll allerdings bis ende des
monats auf den zweit impfungen liegen
hier drängt die zeit bei beyond eck und
moderner muss der zweite pixlr maximal
sechs wochen erfolgen über den impfstoff
in niedersachsen morlin in niedersachsen
schließen die impfzentren tageweise weil
der impfstoff fehlt wie hier in
göttingen nur noch 1300 dosen für erst
impfungen kommen an der fokus auf die
zweit impfungen bremsen die erst
impfungen aus dabei könnten sie hier
noch viel mehr impfen der betreiber des
imf zentrums empört die ganz klare
ansage war wir sollten ebenso das
relativ schnell wieder normalität
unser tägliches geschehen kommt ich
persönlich bin ein bisschen enttäuscht
erst impfungen wird es in 50 impfzentren
in niedersachsen in den nächsten wochen
kaum geben die lieferengpässe von beyond
ecken moderner treffen nicht nur
niedersachsen die deckelung der
impfstoff lieferung an die impfung ist
ein bundesweites thema das ist aus
unserer sicht unerträglich weil wir
gleichzeitig allein in niedersachsen
noch etwa 600.000 menschen auf der
warteliste haben die dringend auf ihre
ersten funkdaten dass potenziale
impfzentren nicht benutzt der
bundesgesundheitsminister bleibt
optimistisch bei seinem besuch in der
bundeswehr apotheke im niedersächsischen
quakenbrück hier werden mehrere corona
im stoffe gelagert und verteilt sparen
spricht von imf tages rekorden von
großen schritten nach vorn mit kleinen
einschränkungen
wir werden jetzt eine phase von zwei
drei wochen haben wo in den impfzentren
wie in den arztpraxen relativ viel mehr
zweitimpfung auch vorgenommen werden und
so richtig steigerung bei den erste
impfungen dann wieder im juni sehen
der impfstoff ist und bleibt ein knappes
gut
weniger infektionen mehr impfungen damit
wächst auch die hoffnung auf einen
langersehnten urlaub im ausland viele
beliebte urlaubsländer der deutschen
lockern schon jetzt ihre bestimmungen
nach spanien ist die einreise bereits
möglich italien will die quarantäne
pflicht morgen aufheben
in österreich öffnen nächste woche
hotels und gastronomie und heute hat
auch griechenland zahlreiche
beschränkungen gelockert an seinem stern
berichtet vorsichtig aber voller
tatendrang macht griechenland wieder auf
eröffnet eine tourismussaison auf die so
viele so lange gewartet haben
seit dem morgenland in etwa auf kreta
wie der ferienflieger aus deutschland
ausgebuchte maschinen bringen
urlaubsreife urlauber auf die insel
super befreiend es ist herrlich ganz
einfach mussten test machen buchen und
legen ein aktueller negativer pcr test
ist pflicht es sei denn man hat den
vollen impfschutz reise virus regeln mit
dabei in diesem urlaub und zwar überall
abstand desinfektionsmittel oder eine
ausgangssperre von 0 30 bis 5 uhr
trotzdem entspannen absolut möglich
sagen sie hier kurz nach der ankunft
heute mittag am strand das ist für mich
pure erholung ich bin hier angekommen
war schon wie ausgewechselt
eine leitende branche hofft auf viele
erholungssuchende in normalen zeiten
macht der tourismus mehr als 20 prozent
der griechischen wirtschaftsleistung aus
in der letzten saison hatten wir leider
einen einbruch um 80 prozent im
vergleich zum vorjahr
das war eine katastrophe für die
hoteliers und viele andere auf kreta
öffnen heute etwa 160 hotels von gut
1600 immerhin ein anfang
denn auch kreuzfahrtschiffe sind hier ab
heute wieder unterwegs ist tut sich
etwas auf der reise richtung normalität
die inflationsrate in deutschland ist
viel zu niedrig oft war diese klage in
den letzten jahren von volkswirten zu
hören
jetzt aber ist die jährliche teuerung
gestiegen so stark wie seit zwei jahren
nicht mehr und so klagen andere
autofahrer an der tankstelle etwa oder
alle die heizen müssen
energie ist nämlich der große
preistreiber stefan schlosser über die
gründe
das frühjahr war deutlich zu kalt der
heizöl vorrat hat sich dem ende für
einen vollen tank muss bernd weigel im
vergleich zum vorjahr aber deutlich
tiefer in die tasche greifen
mit einführung der co2 steuer zu
jahresbeginn haben sich die
energiekosten deutlich verteuert das
merken autofahrer auch an der tankstelle
dazu treiben manch knappe produkte wie
halbleiter und baustoffe die inflation
nachdem das preisniveau monate lang
sogar gesunken ist ist die inflation
aktuell mit 2 prozent im april so hoch
wie seit zwei jahren nicht mehr
und sie dürfte noch weiter steigen auf
rund 3 prozent sagen prognosen
allerdings wohl nur kurzzeitig ich
glaube schon dass seinem nächsten jahr
die inflation wieder sinken wird dass
sie zurückgehen wird denn die
lohnabschluss in deutschland sind sehr
moderat so dass die arbeitskosten die
inflation wieder drücken werden
längerfristig könnte es aber anders
aussehen
die europäische zentralbank hat die
geldschleusen während der krise noch
weiter geöffnet und macht keine
anstalten sie zu schließen
somit dürfte auch in den kommenden
jahren zu viel geld in die
realwirtschaft kommen und da spricht
dafür dass auf die längere sicht doch
beträchtliche inflationsrisiken im
euroraum bestehen zurzeit eine
komplizierte lage mit vielen
unwägbarkeiten sicher scheint nur
billiger wird es nicht werden nicht nur
beim heizöl und nun zum spannenden
dfb-pokalfinale gestern abend in berlin
zwischen leipzig und dortmund herbert
behrens starkes spiel beider
mannschaften die borussia aber einfach
cleverer cooler die drei torchancen für
den bvb in halbzeit eins eiskalt
ausgenutzt in der zweiten spielen
machte leipzig mächtig druck endstand 4
2 1 für feuchtfröhlich feiern die
dortmunder spieler attacke auf trainer
terrasse den sie als architektin ihres
erfolgs feiern
wir sind unglaublich glücklich aber auch
unglaublich stolz dass wir das als
mannschaft geschafft haben im
olympiastadion ohne zuschauer
entwickelte sich ein hochklassiges spiel
censo mit finesse nach nur fünf minuten
zum 1 0 über den herausragenden kapitän
reus und den ebenfalls groß
aufspielenden rollen für das 2 0 und
wieder durch sancho das 3 0 vor der
pause
leipzig trainer nagelsmann gelang es
seine elf neu zu motivieren aber erst in
der 71 minute versenkte olmo den ball im
bvb tor zu spät holland glückte im
berliner dauerregen sogar das 4 2 1 beim
insgesamt fünften pokalsieg des bvb
alexander zverev ist beim atp-turnier in
rom ausgeschieden er verlor in einem
packenden viertelfinale gegen den
spanier rafael nadal in zwei sätzen
sandplatzkönig rafael nadal macht von
beginn an deutlich er will diesmal als
sieger vom platz gehen die deutsche
nummer eins alexander zverev hatte gegen
den grand slam rekordsieger zuletzt
dreimal in folge gewinnen können und
trotz anfänglicher schwierigkeiten spürt
man auch in rom
das wäre will gewinnen dennoch muss
ersatz 1 mit 3 6 abgeben
der zweite satz dagegen auf augenhöhe es
wäre immer wieder mit breakchancen doch
nadal beendet das hochklassige match
verwandelt nach fast zwei stunden seinen
ersten matchball zum 6 4 und steht im
halbfinale
dritte medaille für wasserspringer
patrick hausding bei der schwimm-em in
budapest zusammen mit lars rüdiger
gewann er die goldmedaille im
synchronspringen vom drei meter brett
das berliner duo verwies die russischen
titelverteidiger auf den zweiten platz
bronze ging an die ukraine
übrigens das siebzehnte em gold dient
sieht wunderschön aus
dank neue schauer und gewitter sind
morgen unterwegs die details beim wetter
gleich von präsident ali so viel von uns
claus kleber erwartet sie um 10 zum
heute-journal und wir freuen uns morgen
wieder auf sie punkt 19 uhr
danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit und einen
angenehmen start ins wochenende
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ziemlich
unbeständig geht es sogar über das
kommende wochenende hinaus dieser
riesige tief komplex hier über mittel
und nordeuropa setzt sich fest und so
kommen immer wieder tiefs herangerauscht
bringen regen mit sehen sie hier in blau
und etwas kühlere luft und du sitzt in
der nacht aus die schauer lassen
allmählich nach es lockert teilweise auf
im norden bildet sich nebel
bei zwei bis neun grad und morgen kommt
von westen schauer und gewitter auf
schon in den vormittagsstunden nach
osten und norden hin gibt es viel
sonnenschein oder auch im süden richtung
südosten regnet es ebenfalls zum
nachmittag denen sich die schauer und
gewitter nach osten und norden aus vor
allem im norden gibt es dann teils
kräftige gewitter mit hagel und
sturmböen ganz im südosten bleibt es am
längsten trocken bei höchsten
temperaturen von 19 grad in den
östlichen landesteilen und zwölf in der
eifel in den nächsten tagen wenig
änderungen schauer und gewitter ziehen
immer wieder durch temperaturen 12 bis
18 grad am sonntag dienstag 11 bis 17
ein schöner abend